o ame
hum o meu nome é pedro fabião eu sou
palhaço do hospital que é um palhaço
especializado em fazer rir pessoas
doentes aqui alguém doente
ninguém doente então vão ser dois
minutos
eu tentei avisar a organização mas
porque era vamos ter aqui alguém doente
nem que seja a porta alguém realmente
constipada com uma gripe a expirar em
cima das pessoas então ficávamos todos
doentes este imensa piada não foi aceita
a proposta é para valer quando
convidaram pra plantar aqui em cima a
fazer esta coisa vocês aí embaixo
olharam com 1 500 pessoas a olhar com
olhos à vista disseram que era pra fazer
alguma coisa sobre o riso
eu tenho uma idéia de fazer uma coisa
não tão paulo as tramas mais uma
experiência partilhada e gostava que
alguém partilhar comigo este momento de
sentir um pouco 500 pessoas a para nós
quando se calhar vamos olhar todos aqui
para esta sexta feira que está aqui
olhamos tudo pra ela com episódios que
vocês tanto pra mim quanto por pp favor
é samsung junho
obrigado agora temos tudo pra ela vira
pra wii
a aí eu fiquei mais roxa é então
obrigado senhor vem bastante mas todas
as pessoas mereciam isso todos os dias
ao levantar-se da cama a curvar evento
500 pessoas
vais conseguir mas não despede manda
energia enorme
vamos 12 times cada
este é o meu mundo ideal é bom que o
convidaram para vir aqui falar sobre o
riso e eu normalmente convivem com uma
coisa eu só conheço a palavra sim para
responder ao convite pois passavam mesmo
sem pensar num eu aceitei falar sobre o
riso
eu só estou habituado a fazer rir não
teve tanta falar sobre isso quando eu
faço treinamento quase não usa a palavra
então isso pra mim é uma situação única
vem estranho tem que ouvir minha voz e
miguel esquisito no microfone ea mas
pronto antes vamos experimentar esquecem
do texto obriga só fazendo e se entregar
ao canto com antecedência foi ontem à
uma da manhã e eu já escrevi porque eu
não sou incapaz de se utilizar do país
então não sei que vou dizer mas vamos
vamos vamos falar sobre o que é ser
palhaço e pois também a crença do que é
ser palhaço hospital
ser palhaço é uma profissão um caminho
estranho né
- quando vou às finanças e pronto
profissão ele espalhasse at
imagine um caso estranho e também foi
para os meus pais quando eu e minha mãe
dizer nem e emprego em goiás
o silêncio durante cinco minutos mas
pronto desde então eu tenho vivido um
porquê nem como um palhaço o que é isto
é vamos cantar uma ou duas histórias da
minha vida é só pra vocês verem que não
é nada diferente das vossas vidas alguém
vamos contar a história que aconteceu a
um emmy e um mês quando meu filho nasceu
meu filho faz hoje um ano e um mês e eu
para vencer muriel é e tivemos o parto
no hospital a que o é
quem já teve filho estava em um fronte
gaal se vai se estávamos eu e minha meta
lançar vamos pra casa agora com como
este centro estava entrando no carro
vamos 10 min
vamos a um parque passear pois três dias
no hospital
então eu damos o seu viver no porto na
altura andávamos à procura de um lugar
para estacionar a num parque não havia
estávamos a 45 minutos a procurar um
lugar para estacionar com o filho recém
nascido em limeira exausta eu e na não
tinha descomprimindo então eu vi o
instituto nacional do sangue
acho que é assim que se chama e tem um
parque de estacionamento totalmente
livre de assinar aqui é estacionou e e
ao sair e vamos aceitar que os
seguranças vai dizer se o sangue eo sim
isso por essa raiva por aqui por favor
e ele sabe e eu já votei nele e eu sair
eu vou 200 cargos
eu vou estar lá dentro você por outra
porta então cheguei ao balcão e será o
número do cartão de cidadão e daí eu só
já temos aqui a sua filha bola entrar e
concentrar e como já tinha ficha feito
foi casas noturnas que já tenham de
dados em sentar num ghani chutaram uma
uma agulha e tirar um meio litro de
sangue
no fim eu trouxe meu filho para casa e
quando tem investido e minha mulher a
superar no parque
isso é uma coisa que acontece é que eu
não podia pegar meu filho
bom eu acho todas já viveram histórias
de sempre ela não tão idiotas mas isso é
uma coisa correta e é nestes momentos
que aparece a nossa parte e eu acho
todas as postagens esta partida uma
parte palhaço dentro de si uma parte que
não consegue controlar a realidade por
mais que tentemos format que a gente
tenha planos isso acontecer vou
trabalhar duro e que vai acontecer
ou eu tenho essa expectativa e isso vai
voltar tudo correr bem eu vou é meu
plano quando estava na escola era ser
psicólogo por acaso não sei como
consegui fui mas já era palhaço nessa
altura ea vida prega-nos partidas a
realidade nem sempre eles nosso e nós só
temos uma do temos duas opções ou nos
sentimos um carinho miados e sentimos
derrotados porque a realidade está aí
nós ou centenas
olha o fazer vir alguém eu eu eu não sei
ainda muito bem se acredita em deus não
mas as pessoas que eu conheço não
acredito desenhar deus existe é um
desejo muita sabe qo as coisas no mundo
quando eu canto eu acho que deus existe
é um deus com o sentido do modo
espetacular
imagina se eu escrever essa história que
eu quero cantar e fazer mal estacionados
eu vou liberá lo em segurança
eu acho que eu estou constantemente
visto bom voltando ao tema do palhaço é
que o que o palhaço treina e desenvolve
a usar todos temos uma faca para
trabalhar essas opções que tem uma
compulsão de fazer trilhas outras
pessoas só sentem bem quando estão a
fazer vida das outras pessoas
e são pessoas que trazem no um jantar a
sós eles vêem no jantar há sempre o
inglês e injetar uma pessoa que inventa
é o governo cortou e nós damos esse
lugar aquela pessoa e estamos que ela
esteja lá serão imediatas
isso permite também estava intenção aí
no povo
permite também contactar contactar com a
nossa parte e volta ea opressão mês de
maio é uma instituição que é feita de
pessoas assim é uma espécie de vazio de
deus pra ambientes com oscips e nós
trabalhamos em contexto hospitalar ou
seja escolhemos e prolongar mais difícil
fazer rir e se calhar mais difícil que é
o lugar onde a realidade nos prega mais
partidas
é o maior descontrole nós podemos ter é
a doença e até morte é um da nossa
limitação é mais evidente e nós seguimos
e aqui em portugal foi beatriz quintela
e eu queria eu sempre falo em público
fez um agradecimento enorme ela faleceu
há pouco mais de um ano e foi fundador e
presidente da praça de maio e sem ela
não existia essa organização
e ela com som tv este sonho e com o sol
está organizando hoje em dia está
presente nas quatro maiores cidades
portuguesas e visita dizendo as mulheres
crianças por ano e o que nós fazemos no
fundo é o varejista olhar que transforma
a realidade que vê no meio dos dramas
que todos nós vivemos pensei 'por uma
brecha onde alguma coisa que nos traz
leveza
eu contratei esta pessoa para quando o
processo visa ouvir sessão
e agora para toda a gente sentir um
caminho que é que é isso quando eu falo
encontrou que esses controlos contra uma
coisa desagradável e o kripta agentes da
psp e vamos jogar um jogo que eu dos
jogos mais simples que existisse a toda
a gente já jogou choveu o rei manda
ok o rei manda fazer uma coisa vocês
fazem surrey não mandar não é pra fazer
que o clube suíço então o ray manda o
levantar um braço
o remo não levantar o outro vai ter uma
palma bater outra mandou bater outra vez
e então o rei manda nem mandou sentar
mandou o real mandou levantar o olhar
proponho a guerra o remendo olhar
procurei no ar o rei mandou piscar o
olho a mandar um beijinho
a vitória de são roque o rei manda
mostrar o lugar
o rei vai mostrar outro lugar esconder
os plugados ok
o rei manda dar às nossas carteiras a
oradora ok 60 anos o rei mandou sentar
obrigar venceu o irlandês em dário eo
gaiman acabar o jogo
por mais que a gente seja certinho por
mais que nós sejamos sérios e teremos
controlar a qualidade
vejo técnicos acontece parece que temos
um problema genético sem drogas vez está
com palhaço treinar durante a vida toda
é promover este lado o pateta estava em
alta para dizer que nós somos feitos
para ser aquilo que somos seres falava
isso fez que fracassam seres que vivem
na corda bamba
nunca nunca sabemos quando é que vai
acontecer alguma coisa boa ou quando é
que vai acontecer uma coisa má
isto é é é a natureza humana e que nós
fazemos é a natureza humana é
amplificada o valor extremo é que eu
tenho a sensação que está a acontecer
uma espécie de um movimento em portugal
já há três grupos para o hospital a
pagar sem fronteiras a confiantes cada
vez mais presentes em todos os média as
pessoas sentem necessidade de ir ea este
evento é uma necessidade enorme deveria
valorizar como nunca desvalorizaram em
portugal é a comédia e humor
por quê
por cada vez mais nós vemos como em suas
única e desmesurada na razão na eficácia
na finança dinheiro com essas três
ae então nós precisamos de nada pode
ficar a sós aprovado nós possamos
compensar o positivo eo negativo e humor
está aqui para isso e nós precisamos
acima todo o contacto humor e o riso é a
distância mais curta entre duas pessoas
tanto quanto nós nos crimes com o ganho
é impossível estarmos mais próximos
dessa pessoa e eu vou casar com quem
jogo muito rápido e que vocês conhecem
uma pessoa voz suave e eficaz em 2 a 2
dura 30 segundos ok eu sei que essa
escolha mais difícil é quem é que vai
sentir menos mal
será que ninguém vai dar pra mim
escolha uma pessoa rapidamente e eu
vamos pedir eu vou te pedir em goiana pe
que fica em frente a frente com essa
pessoa
ok depois gravamos está a pausa do café
é um brinde e agora vamos convir que
estejam em absoluto silêncio
ok e fiquem à distância de um braço da
outra pessoa calma não se empurra ea uma
onde vocês que vai inspirar e expirar
visivelmente com outra pessoa e o colega
vai tentar inspirar e expirar exatamente
ao mesmo tempo em sincronia
ok saem caretas sem comentários vinhos
só a estar em contacto com o nosso
colega são só 30 segundos vocês aguentam
tem olhar realmente pra cara do vosso
colega para olhar duas coisas
de onde vem esta pessoa que tribo esta
vai jogar como se fosse um
extraterrestre nunca tivessem visto
ninguém semelhantes porque nunca viram
veja o que é absolutamente ridículo na
cara do vosso colega céu também do nariz
das entradas às muralhas
há tantas coisas na casa fosse colega
vejo também que o carro maravilhoso
o brilho no olhar a humanidade o
nervosismo
muito obrigado
eu sei é desconfortável
ninguém disse que se confrontava isso
que vocês fizeram agora é que o que nós
ao profissionalismo e fazem ao entrar em
cada quarto é brites e ver como os olhos
absoluta novidade é que o que existe
dentro daquilo quarto que o pessoal que
está aí qual é no dia que ela tem até
aquela pode vir até nós entrar no quarto
nós somos o único profissional que a
criança pode dizer rua e nós vamos
porque temos dá poder à criança e à cabo
e agradecendo a organização e vocês
todos gostarem aqui e adquirirem este
movimento dos prêmios screen ou anda
aqui em portugal e que a gente possa
mudar realmente alguma coisa
o propósito
ó